so you're a billionaire and you've run
into a problem you've amassed all this
wealth all this power but you're getting
old and your kids your nieces your
nephews they're all lining up to kiss
your butt to make sure they get listed
on the will but your family doesn't know
anything about money they didn't have to
grind it out like you did everything was
given to them so if you leave any money
to them they are gonna squander it no
seriously a staggering 70 of wealthy
families lose their wealth by the Next
Generation with 90 losing it by the
generation after that two generations
that is all it takes for all your wealth
all your hard work the Empire you've
built to go circling down the drain you
cannot let that happen but lucky for you
ultra wealthy dynasties have already
figured out how to solve this problem
and at the center of it all are the
Rockefellers who after 80 years since
his death Seven Generations later John D
rockefeller's family is still standing
as one of the wealthiest families on
Earth how wealthy well no one knows
because they're just that good at hiding
it and in this video we are gonna expose
it all trusts Family Foundation family
offices and a super clever tactic that
not many people know about stay
dangerous this is how the rich get
richer and this is definitely not
Financial advice
foreign
here's what you have to understand about
the ultra wealthy versus the masses the
masses want to get rich so they can own
the lambo so they can own the yacht the
Mansion the private jets they want to
show it off they want to flaunt their
wealth but owning stuff is for the
peasants when you legally own something
leeches wants to sue you every chance
they get these want to steal from you
the government wants to tax you into
Oblivion ambitious prosecutors want to
take you down and the plebs want to
pillage you that is why the ultra
wealthy do not want to own stuff because
owning stuff sucks instead what you want
to do is have control over your assets
as if you owned it without actually
owning it you want to live in the
penthouse on billionaires row without it
being tied to your name you want to sell
your mega yacht without it being under
your name just ask the Russian oligars
if they agree the key is control not
ownership you want to be able to do
everything you can with the thing as if
you owned it without having your name on
the papers because when you have
ownership taxes follow you and liability
follows you and also sometimes Fame
follows you and so those three things
could be problematic and the people that
are really wealthy want control but they
don't necessarily want the liability
that comes with ownership and they don't
necessarily want the taxation that files
title and ownership and so many many of
the wealthiest people in the world we
don't even know their names because they
have a ton of control but they're not
names they're not personally on a lot of
assets and and wealth and that's really
the name of the game this is my friend
Caleb by the way with better wealth and
he's dedicated his life to learning how
the ultra wolfy do things to bring down
that knowledge to Everyday People Like
Us do you think there's richer people
out there than you know the people that
we see on the Forbes list like Bezos
Yeah a hundred percent there's there's
people that are way way wealthier and
the people on the Forbes list because of
entities and structures and other things
that they control that they're not
giving credit for and they do it
intentionally but how do you control
something without owning it simple the
elite have created certain entities
they've created certain tools that give
you all the control you want while
technically on paper you're as broke as
the bigger on the streets and the first
tool that family is like the
Rockefellers use is called a trust
[Music]
thank you in 1934 John D Rockefeller Jr
established trust for his daughter and
five sons that consisted of oil company
stocks and real estate holdings these
trusts still hold the bulk of the
fortune another set of trusts were set
up in 1952 for his grandchildren the
fourth generation of the family but why
why trust think of a trust like a
corporation but for your family you put
your money and real estate and
businesses into this trust and once the
money is in the trust you can invest
that money however you want you get to
set the rules for what happens to your
money when you die but most importantly
just like a corporation once you put
money in the trust you do not own it
anymore the trust owns that money you
win the trust or completely separate
legal entities you give up all the
ownership of that money but none of the
control so on paper maybe you're worth a
measly 10 million dollars but in reality
you might be worth over a hundred
billion dollars with all that money
safely stashed in hundreds of different
trusts and because these trusts don't
directly belong to you your money is
protected if you get sued or something
they can't come after the money you have
in your trust just like how if you sued
a corporation in they don't have any
money you're not going to get a cent out
of the founders personal bank accounts
also in America we have a death tax
which means when you die and you pass on
your money to your kids they're gonna
get hit with a death tax of up to 40 one
of the highest in the world and Trust
help your kids avoid that pesky death
tax that way when you die you're a kiss
just take your place on the Board of
Trustees and all the control that comes
with it but trusts are just one part of
the succession plan what really ties
everything all together is this next
tool that is very very sneaky
thank you
[Music]
when you hear the word life insurance it
conjures up images like this and for the
average pleb life insurance is exactly
nuts but for the ultra wealthy life
insurance is this insanely powerful tool
that they keep on their reps there's a
reason why the Rockefeller family has
their own life insurance company the
Rockefeller insurance company that's
because for the ultra wealthy they use
life insurance as kind of like a bank
account but not just any ordinary bank
accounts they use life insurance as kind
of like a super bank account that can be
used to invest tax-free it sounds weird
but this is because all Life Insurance
is as a contract a contract that has
some very nice tax benefits because
politicians don't want to tax the poor
Widow that just lost her husband the
problem is the traditional life
insurance policies that are sold to the
masses absolutely suck they're made to
enrich the insurance companies and not
you you buy a life insurance plan you
pay some money every month to your
insurance company and in exchange when
you die the company gives your family a
couple million dollars nothing more and
nothing less so what the ultra wolf we
do is they take this basic contract and
they just negotiate better terms and
this allows the ultra wealthy to do
something very very special they put as
much money as they want into their life
insurance policy where it grows tax-free
and then they use that money that they
put into the life insurance policy to
invest in whatever they want so their
Investments grow tax-free your money's
safe it will grow the rest of your life
it will grow tax deferred you can use
your money tax-free it will get passed
on tax free it has a lot of other
benefits and so what the wealthy you use
it is they don't use it as an investment
they use it as like a safe asset I call
it the and asset because they're able to
give their dollars more than one job and
so they're able to do that while it's
protected while it's off the radar
screen of the IRS because it's not
considered income that's how a lot of
wealthy people use it and then step
number three is usually what they to
take the money or to utilize the money
you're not withdrawing your money what a
lot of people do because that would be
in a lot of cases taxable upon gain
they're borrowing against it or using a
third party Bank to borrow against their
asset and as a result if you borrow
against it it's not considered income so
a lot of wealthy people like Elon Musk
and all these people they're they're
borrowing against the equity in their
businesses insurance and when you Max
Fund Insurance that's why a bunch of
banks do this is over 3 000 Banks today
have what's called Bank on life
insurance some of their safest Assets in
the bank is in bank owned life insurance
why do they do that it's it's an asset
that they can borrow against and key
team members and employees and so many
institutions use life insurance not as a
death benefit but as an and as a place
to store and use their money but not
only that just like a trust the money
that the rich put in their life
insurance policies are also protected
from creditors and legal penalties but
where things get really crazy is when
the rich start borrowing money against
their own life insurance policy and then
they use that money to invest in more
assets so basically what rich people do
is they put let's say a million bucks
into their insurance policy and uh that
money in their insurance policy they
invest it into like the stock market or
something and it returns seven percent
and the whole game is borrowing like
100k from that million at like a lower
or interest rate on your loan at like
three percent so yes that's exactly it
so in just very conservative numbers if
you borrowed at five percent and you
earn seven percent your money and your
insurance is continuing to grow and
you're getting all the benefits of
insurance but on that borrowed at five
earning seven that's a forty percent
rate of return in the first year so
you're getting a forty percent rate of
return on on that side and people might
say that doesn't make sense you're
becoming the bank you're using Arbitrage
your investment is the five percent not
the full money because your money is in
your policy continuing to compound so
the same thing goes with making a
greater rate of return is you the
benefit of this is having a dollar doing
more than one thing and the people that
borrow against it they have to make sure
that their activities get a greater
return than what the cost of borrowing
and if you can do that you can really
have a dollar doing more than one job
but how does taking a loan out on your
own life insurance policy even work like
where do you even go to Doula you could
go right to the insurance company and
they give you an unstructured loan no
questions asked and you could Say Hey I
want a 200 000 lien it's it's almost
like a HELOC but it's an unstructured so
when you go to a bank and get a loan you
have to pay that money back an insurance
company you don't have to pay that money
back because they know that you're gonna
die someday and they have that
unilateral contract and they're paying
upon your debt so the cool thing is Jake
you have this outstanding loan a 200 000
loan you're doing things with it and you
never pay that money back when you die
the insurance company is going to pay
out your beneficiary your family minus
what you owe them so insurance is one of
the only institutions that doesn't
require you to have to pay back that
loan because they're hedging both sides
or hedging your mortality and they're
also hedging interest rate and because
they're a lifelong contract commitment
they're going to last a lot longer than
we live they can play the ultimate long
game and so we call these loans but
they're just a more efficient way to use
money and you can decide if you want to
pay them back because it's either going
to come out of your legacy yeah it's
either going to come out of your legacy
or out of your pocket while you're alive
makes sense so when you say unstructured
that means that there's no like
repayment terms like I don't know how
you decide yeah unstructured means you
decide when you pay them if you pay them
how much interest you pay them and and
you're really in control because you are
the owner of that contract but where
really ties everything back together is
that when your kids die you said enough
so that the money that gets paid from
their life insurance policy goes right
back into the Family Trust when kids are
born into the Rockefeller family they
buy a bunch of life insurance on them
and obviously the kids are able to buy
things and you know continue to spend
but at the end of the day when they die
they have a massive death benefit that
goes back to the trust replenishing the
Trust on what they spend during their
life so the way that a lot of people can
incorporate something like this in their
own life is each generation has life
insurance and they have what's called
Max funded life insurance and so they're
using it for like a bank and they're
using it to buy other things and maybe
some of them have outstanding loans well
what happens when the next Generation
dies and the death benefit gets paid
those that death benefit could
ultimately pay back your outstanding
loan and you're getting all the benefits
of compounding so we call this the
waterfall effect because if every
generation had life insurance you're
almost guaranteeing every generation is
going to be better off no matter what
decisions they make during their life
because they're ultimately upon their
death will reset the the trust or the
family fund all while giving you control
and access to use and invest all while
you're alive and when Caleb realized
that the ultra wealthy were doing all
this he knew that he had to share with
the rest of us so you can think about
this from a standpoint of from day one
you have safety it's easily accessible
you have great growth rate you're able
to use it there's built-in guarantees
and you're you're compounding your money
tax-free that gives you options for the
future and you have protections whether
you die or you get really sick before
all that time you have an asset that's
continuing to compound for you no other
asset no other paper asset gives you
anywhere near those benefits all while
giving you control to do what you want
with your money that's that's what for
me was like oh from day one I can
control my money and invest it and use
it for whatever I want and I get all the
benefits that's that for me was like
okay they're neat more people need to
hear about this because we haven't been
told the truth as it relates to the
power of this asset which is why Caleb
created better wealth to take the
strategies that the ultra Wolfie uses
and make them available to smaller fish
like you and I and if you think that
this overfunded life insurance strategy
is something that you would want to do
pause the video and go to
betterwealth.com Jake with the link
below to learn more that's better
wealth.com Jake with the link below to
learn more more information on this
later but better wolf is the pace
sponsor of this video and I am not a
registered financial advisor so check
with professionals before making any
financial decisions and make sure you
don't go anywhere yet because no family
Dynasty is complete without the good old
family Foundation
at some point in building your Empire
you're going to realize that you have
literally too much money to spend at a
certain point buying another Mansion
Supercar private jet even another decent
investment is not going to change
anything for you and that is where the
Family Foundation comes in ah yes good
old charity you can create a foundation
put some of your money there not get
taxed on any of that money and you'll
still have control over it wink wink and
there are many benefits to having a
foundation on one hand your foundation
will make you look all Noble and
generous it makes your wolf a little bit
more palpable to the masses he is a
billionaire but at least he's also a
philanthropist it's a good PR move on
the other hand legally you're only
required to spend five percent of your
foundation's money on charity every year
only five percent the rest you can use
to hire family members and pay them a
generous full-time salary you can use it
to get your name plastered on your
University Building the big thing is
there's a lot of wealthy people in the
news that are praised for giving most
their wealth away okay and it's it's
amazing and I think it's awesome that
they're doing that but they understand
that if you donate or give your money
away it's you know you get a deduction
you don't have to pay taxes on that so
what the wealthy families do instead of
giving Monies to Charities that they
don't have control of they create their
own private family Foundation which is
their own non-profit giving essentially
and they're able to donate to that
organization again they're not donating
to themselves because it's the
foundation it's its own entity but I
wonder who controls that entity Jake
they do their families do and so they
control these massive amounts of wealth
and they can ultimately decide where
that money goes what they do with that
money who the cost of running that
foundation and on and on and on and so
I'm not saying that wealthy families
aren't charitable that's not true at all
I'm just saying that they give
strategically they get a bunch of
deductions today and they maintain
control of that money and they only have
to to give away a fraction and part of
the the fraction of what they need to
give away can ultimately get paid for
operating the the foundation and so
there's stories across the board of
people that are being super super
generous with their foundations people
that are setting up private family
foundations and barely giving anything
away but they're using it as another
rapper to look charitable but to
ultimately just control money and so a
lot of families have a foundation at the
bottom of their structure because at the
end of the day all the money eventually
will flow down to the foundation and the
foundation is another example of control
entities and it's another example when
set up and used properly is an amazing
Legacy tool to pass on money the Next
Generation in rockefeller's case he
didn't use foundations as just a way to
control his money no he started the
Rockefeller Foundation to mold Society
into his vision he used the Rockefeller
Foundation to create the modern day
education system as we know it click the
card on the top right corner to watch
that video super good he used this
Foundation to push modern Western
medicine and vaccines and to suppress
other alternative the forms of medicine
video coming soon make sure you
subscribe but what can you say when
you're a man that has it all what is
there left to do other than to change
the world into whatever you believe it
should be and in terms of where your
foundation is in your web of Trust
Insurance corporations Etc your family
Foundation is going to be at the very
bottom of everything
well it's it's at the bottom because a
lot of times foundations are not a
for-profit it's not creating wealth and
so a lot of times the money is created
it's either created through ownership
and Investments and so it usually when
it talks about flowing down at the end
of the day a lot of time the way that
money gets into a private family
Foundation it's either donated or flows
from a trust and so by default
foundations don't necessarily create a
ton of income they usually are an entity
that you would flow or donate an example
of this is when Mark Zuckerberg donated
a bunch of his wealth to his foundation
it's like that's an example of he made
all of his money by being an
entrepreneur and then he donated and you
have a ton of examples of this of people
donating to private family foundations
and there you have it at the top the
patriarch makes all the money he then
puts the money into trust the family
members are a part of the trust and they
each get their own life insurance
policies any extra money can be put into
the Family Foundation for other
strategic goals and when the family
members die their death benefit from the
life insurance goes right back into the
trust to keep the family pot growing and
to manage all of this you have what's
called a family office basically a group
of the best of the best wealth
management advisors to deal with this
giant mess and there's a reason you
probably haven't heard about most of
this the wealthy have tried to keep
trust foundations Insurance all of this
on the down low mainly mainly because
again they don't want to create a
spotlight to how they're controlling and
passing on money and so that it's the
same people that will create confusion
in the education system these are the
same people that are saying life
insurance is a horrible place to put
your money they know it's not an
investment but they love Financial
pundit saying that it is and as a result
many people are just buying term
investing in the stock market doing
their thing putting their head down and
are getting broker and broker every
generation because they're not
controlling and using their money like
the wealthy so one of the biggest
reasons most people are not talking
about this life insurance Even in our
industry is majority of people are not
incentivized to do the right thing so
the reason why a majority of life
insurance policies are not set up like
what I've been sharing with you is it
comes down to compensation and
commission we get paid about one tenth
of what a typical life insurance person
would get paid for setting up a policy
the reason for that is we're trying to
keep the policy as flexible and as over
funded as possible and we get paid on
What's called the base premium and and
really the secret behind this is getting
the base as small as possible and using
other ways to front load and finance the
policy and so number one the ultra
wealthy don't want you to know this
because they they've been using these
strategies for years upon years but then
a lot of the people in our space don't
necessarily want you to know about this
because they're making a lot of money
selling typical life insurance policies
for Estate Planning and so the reason
we're able to do this is we play the
long game and we essentially are saying
hey we're gonna play the volume game
we're gonna do the right thing we're
gonna make money helping people set this
up but we know that we're just going to
serve a lot more people and in the end
it's it's a great business for us to be
in but everyone that works with us gets
an incredible policy that's super
flexible that is almost feels illegal to
have
so again if you're interested in using
life insurance in this manner scroll
down and click the link below to go to
betterwealth.com Jake to learn more his
team will get clear about where you're
at and where you want to be to see if
you would actually benefit from the
strategy and if this strategy would help
you they'll walk you through all the
stuffs and help you get set up with
everything and keep in mind Caleb was
telling me how this strategy really only
makes sense if you're able to save at
least ten thousand dollars a year
because there are some fixed costs that
wouldn't make it make sense if you're
only able to put in a few hundred
dollars a month but if that is you
scroll down and click the link below to
go to betterwealth.com Jake to learn
more better wolf is the paid sponsor of
this video and of course I am not a
registered financial advisor you should
always check where your professional
Financial tax and legal advisors before
making any financial decisions this
video is for information purposes only
and as always stay dangerous
[Music]
thank you